this is why I find it remarkable that
you have a positive attitude your mother
decides to have a baby mm-hmm
and it's looking for a guy to have a
baby with mm-hmm and in South Africa she
goes and finds a white guy yep who lives
what down the hall here and this guy's
from what Sweden or Switzerland in
Switzerland yeah and she says hey I need
to make a baby she wanted something that
would be hers she had lived in a world
where nothing was hers and she wanted
her thing that she could love and that
would love her unconditionally why would
she go in South Africa yes a country
fresh with apartheid well I had a [ __ ]
would she go to a white guy because of
my mind you think she'd say to herself
my son's gonna have a hard time now the
mixed race in I I don't think she
thought that far my mom in that moment
only thought the government says I'm not
allowed to be with the white guy and
she's like well then I'm gonna be with a
white guy and the white guy was when he
afraid of this situation though I think
my dad is well he's an interesting
he's extremely swiss and he's swiss
german which is like the ultimate
combination of Precision's
in life he is a completely logical human
being to a fault sometimes so he didn't
he didn't understand apartheid we didn't
understand he doesn't understand racism
in that way like he just like my
favorite thing my dad said because I
asked him once I said hey you are with
here you are with a black woman in South
Africa there's racism everywhere this
and I was like like what how are you
thinking about this and then he goes
like he's like turvy says to be honest
and he says I don't understand yeah I
don't understand I don't understand all
these people racist if you're going to
be racist then Africa is the worst place
to come at you got to come you hate
black people so you come to Africa what
are you doing right just making life
miserable by what you hate and I was
like that is a brilliant way to think of
it he's like why would you come to
Africa if you hate black people yeah it
is safe to say this is the worst place
for you to be so he just did not he was
like yeah I love rolling with black
people I love hanging out in Africa I
love the weather this is where I'm gonna
be but think about in your life if a
woman came up to you and said listen I
want to have a baby and you know there's
no romantic love lay or anything like
that and would you ever in your right
mind say hey okay I'll have sex with you
and you'll have your baby and and then
I'll leave I mean I think I might you
really I'm ditching I get a lot of
after this I think I think I might